Tâm tinh từ chúng tâm kỹ tượng thử văn thị bảo xúc bà đang ở giai bản mạnh nhất cấp 122 tâm bảo cách
đất liên quảng ninh 2 phòng là khoảng hơn 5.5 mấy vị phía đông.
Thế nhưng sau hoàn lưu mấy bảo dộng thiến nên là trong điên này các đặcu ở bác vị bác bộ sẽ bắt đầu chữ
anh hưởng trực tiếp. Chúng tôi đang kết nguyễn người an thang tùng từ chúng quay thời tiết để có những phần
tích chí thiết hơn an thang tùng dịnh liến của các bảo xúc bà đi tư dệ mạnh nhất thế nào?
Bảo xúc bà hiện đang rất mạnh, một phần hoàn lưu của các bảo này thì đang nằm trên đất liên của Trung Quốc
nhưng mà vẫn còn rất mạnh, ở các cường độ tấp 122. Bởi vì nhật độ nước biển nơi mà cơn bảo xúc bà này đã đi qua rất cao.
Quảng 3 bí độ xe thì đây chính là 1 năng lượng rồi rao cho các bảo.
Để lúc này thì tư Việt Nam cho đến các chung tâm dự bảo bảo của tế như là nhật bản, Mỹ,
hành Quốc hay là Trung Quốc thì vẫn đông nhất về giữ bảo đường đi của các bảo này.
Đó là khoảng 20 thì bảo xe đi và bị bất bộ và sau đó thì giảm dân về cường độ.
Gió có hoàn lưu dọng thình ngày từ đây này các đặc khu như là bạch lòng vị, cô tô hay cắt 2, sẽ trị hoàn hường chực tiếp của các bảo này.
Với tôi và đêm mai, gió sẽ mạnh dần lên cấp 6 cấp bẩy sau tăng hình cấp 3 cấp chiến vùng cân tâm bảo được qua là cấp 1 đến cấp 122.
Dật cấp 123, sống biển cao từ 2 đến 5 bình động giữ rồi.
Chên đất liên thì các tình thành từ quảng 9, 2 phòng thương yên ninh mình đến thành hoa và nghe an thì sẽ chữ thất nộ mạnh nhất của gió báo.
Tụi tôi và đêm mai thì gió sẽ mạnh dần lên cấp bẩy đến cấp chiến vùng cân tâm bảo như qua là cấp 1 đến cấp 1 bộ.
Dật cấp 1 bốn còn sâu trong đất liên thì gió mạnh cấp sâu cấp bẩy, giật cấp 3 cấp chiến.
Bà con ở các tình thành trên thì cân nhắn trống đảm bảo an toàn tầu thuyền nơi nèo đậu.
Lòng bè thủy sản, tụi nối là không ở lại trên tầu các trời cân lòng bè khu lui trồng thủy sản khi bảo đủ bộ.
Cân về ra cố chẳng trống nhà cơ, các tiệt cạnh kê các biển quảng cao hay là a phích mà có cơ hội lời mất an toàn cân về đảm bảo an toàn cho các công trình đang thi cơm.
Tưởng ngày 25 tháng 20, tháng 20 thì các bộ các chung bộ sẽ có mơ lớn trong tâm bơ lớn sẽ là khu vực vùng nối và chung vô vực trung dô.
Bà đồng bằng bộ của người tang hóa và người an và tâm lượng mơ dự bảo là tự 2,5 đến 3,5 năm mơ mi lắmet và có như người mơ rất to là trên sảo trong mi lắmet.
Có người cơ sảy ra lũ quát, xả lợ đất cũng như là ngập cũng.
Nên là người dân cân chẳng dí chuyển đến khu vực mà có người cơ về xả lợ đất cũng như là lũ quát và tụi lạ không dí chuyển cho bên ngoài khi bảo đảm đủ bộ.
Thúng tìm tiếp theo, về cơn bảo này thì chúng tôi sẽ còn tiếp tục cập nhật.